I KIND THE COMMITTEE TO ORDER I
HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY HAS
BEEN CALLED BY THE AUTHOR.
THE START OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND I SEE WE HAVE AN AUTHOR
HERE.
MOVING NUMBER I FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB TWENTY THIRTY THREE
MISTER SANTIAGO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO OPEN. GOT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
ONE FIRST I THINK THE CHAIR INTO
AND THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR
HELPING US. TO MAKE THIS A
BETTER BILL HOME I THINK. ANYONE
EXCEPT THE.
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TODAY.
LIKE MANY OF YOU. OPPOSITE WE
KNOW AN ACCOUNT AT A RENTS ARE
RISING ACOSTA CALIFORNIA
REPELLENTS DISTRICTS OUR PEOPLE
STRUGGLE TO MAKE PAYMENTS.
I'M AS YOU'RE WELL AWARE THE
CALIFORNIA.
RENTERS TAX CREDIT WAS
IMPLEMENTED TWO DECADES AGO AND
ITS NOT BEEN UPDATED SINCE.
SO WE'RE PROPOSING TO UPDATE
THEM.
AND THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK MY VOTE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SHOT OF PICKING ON THE OF THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTS.
SYLVIA CRIME HAVE A CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
AFP WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE.
START QUIRK. OF.
SO MY CONCERN HERE IS THAT IN A
TIGHT MARKET LIKE THIS THEY ARE
GIVING PEOPLE MORE MONEY TO PAY
RENT.
AND I'M CONCERNED THAT THE.
.
APARTMENT OWNERS WHO ARE GOOD
PEOPLE BUT I THINK THAT THEY
WOULD MY CONCERN IS THAT THEY
WOULD RAISE.
THEIR RATES BECAUSE OF THE TIGHT
MARKET THEY'RE BASICALLY
CHARGING WHATEVER THE MARKET
WILL BEAR.
AND I JUST THINK THE MONEY THAT
WOULD BE BETTER SPENT IN OF.
BUILDING MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING THEM.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE AND NUMBER
ONE MAKE CREDIT NON REFUNDABLE
NUMBER TO REPLACE COUNTY
ASSESSOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. AND THREE
AT A FIVE YEAR SENSE THAT YOU'VE
ACCEPTED ALL THE AMENDMENTS
CONTRACT. I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIR AND.
IF MY MAY RESPOND MENTOR.
DE DE DE MY MONEY THAT PEOPLE
RECEIVE HER MODEST I DON'T THINK
IT'S MY IT'S MY ASSUMPTION THAT
THAT'S SIXTY DOLLARS.
PER MONTH IT WOULDN'T CHANGE
THE MARKET.
WHOLE HECK OF A LOT.
OR EVEN THEN A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY PER PER COUPLE WHEN
CHANGE THE MARKET. HOW THAT
WOULD BE MY ASSUMPTION AND US
SOME OF IT'S IT'S NOT
REFUNDABLE?
SO IT IT WOULDN'T AYE IT'S MUCH
AND THANK YOU MY TURN I WOULDN'T
RESPECT LESS RIVAL.
AND WE DON'T HAVE ACCORDING TO
ONLY DO THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THINK YOU.
CLEAN FILE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY TWO MISTER GIBSON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL I'M
TWENTY NINE TWENTY TWO. A WHICH
WILL HELP LOW INCOME FAMILIES
BECOME HOMEOWNERS I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS
EFFORTS.
ON WORKING WITH US AND WE
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS.
AS.
THE COMMITTEE HAS RECOMMENDED
CALIFORNIA'S FACING A HOUSING
CRISIS WITH ACE WITH A SERIOUS
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOMES FOR A
WORKING AND MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES.
ALTHOUGH THE LEGISLATURE HAS
BEGUN TO RESPOND TO THIS CRISIS
WHO POLICIES THAT PROMOTES
PRIVATE INVESTMENTS OF FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ARE STILL IN
NEED THIS PROPOSAL WILL
STIMULATE PRIVATE INVESTMENT. IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON PROJECTS
THROUGH TAX CREDITS THIS TAX
CREDITS WOULD BE WOULD
INCENTIVIZE PRIVATE ENTITLEMENT
TO CONTRIBUTE TO QUALITY.
UNQUALIFIED I'M NONPROFIT
BUILDINGS HOMES OF FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES LIKE OTHER
AFFORDABLE TAX CREDIT HOUSING
PROGRAMS THESE PROPERTIES WILL
BE LONG TERM RESALE AND DEED
RESTRICTED. OF THIS.
WILL ENSURE THAT THESE HOMES
REMAIN AFFORDABLE AND IN OUR
COMMUNITY TODAY TO SUPPLY ITS
PROVIDES USE ME OF SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES IS MISS MILLER. ON
THE SECOND DIRECTOR OF THE
HABITAT BICU HUMANITIES
GREATER SACRAMENTO.
I WITNESSES WE ASK YOU KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO THREE THREE
WITNESSES THREE MINUTES PLEASE.
OKAY.
ADAM TURNED MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S LIAM MILLER
AND THE EXECUTOR ACTOR OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA THE STATE SUPPORT
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING FORTY
TWO AFFILIATES THROUGH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND WHERE THE
SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE AS YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA REMAINS IN STATE
OF CRISIS WHEN IT COMES TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. HOWEVER
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE SPECIFICALLY
AS ARE THE LOWEST SINCE THE
NINETEEN FORTIES AND TWELVE OF
THE TOP FIFTEEN MOST EXPENSIVE
HOUSING MARKETS REMAIN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY OTHER MANY
OTHER NOT FOR PROFIT HOME
BUILDERS HAVE BEEN CREATING
AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORKING LOWER
INCOME FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA FOR MANY YEARS.
BERMAN CONSULATE CHALLENGED BY
THE RISING COST OF LAND AND
CONSTRUCTION IN SACRAMENTO AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE
GREATEST HURDLE THAT TO BUILDING
MORE HOMES AS FINANCING AND THIS
HURDLE. INCLUDE STATE LOCAL AND
FEDERAL FUNDS BUT ALSO FINDING
MONEY TO CLOSE THE GAP ON THAT
HOUSING. AND IN SACRAMENTO
SPECIFICALLY I'M ONE OF OUR
GREATEST CHALLENGES IS THAT WE
DO HAVE LAND TO BUILD ON THAT
BUT THE COST OF BUILDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS SO GREAT. THAT
TO THIS TIME WHERE BUILDING ONES
INTO THE KIND OF COME SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES AND THAT WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD EVEN
GREATER TO MAKE A GREATER IMPACT
BY BUILDING MULTI FAMILY IS A
LOT OF OUR AFFILIATES DO ACROSS
THE STATE.
ONE OF OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGES I
THINK IT'S PUTTING A FACE TO THE
NAME OF THE FAMILIES THAT WE DO
SERVE THOSE FAMILIES OFTENTIMES
OF THOSE THAT ARE. THOSE LOW
INCOME HARD WORKING FAMILIES
THAT YOU MIGHT NOT SEE ON THE
STREET IS HOMELESS BUT THEY ARE
ON THE VERGE OF HOMELESSNESS.
AND OUT ONE STRAIGHT LIKE TO
SHARE WITH YOU IS OUT THAT OF
JIMMY AND PETTY GARRIDO'S IN A
STORY THAT WAS MOST RECENTLY
FEATURED ON.
AND PR THEY LIVE IN SOUTH LOS A
LOS ANGELES AND DAMN THEY HAVE
HOLES IN THEIR IN THEIR WALLS
WHERE AM IN RECENT STORMS HAVE
SOAKED THROUGH AND DAMAGE THEIR
DRY WALL. AND THEY PUT
DECORATIONS OVER THEM IN ORDER
TO COVER UP THOSE HOLES THEY
HAVE RODENT INFESTATIONS THEY
CURRENTLY PAY SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND.
AND RENTS EACH MONTH FOR THEIR
FAMILY OF FOUR IN A TWO BEDROOM
HOUSE AND WERE RECENTLY TOLD
THAT THEIR BUILDING WAS TO BE
SOLD IN SOUTHERN LOOKING FOR A
NEW PLACE TO LIVE AND UNABLE TO
FIND ANYTHING LESS THAN THREE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH.
AND THE LOOK AT BEING FORCED TO
MOVE SEVENTY MILES OUT OF TOWN
TO THEN HAVE TO UPROOT THEIR
FAMILY THE SCHOOL WHERE THEIR
DAUGHTER GOES TO SCHOOL IS AN
HONOR STUDENT THE ALL THREE OF
THE DOLLARS HONOR STUDENTS. AND
SO THEY CAN FIND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND BE ABLE TO COME BACK
INTO THE CITY TO THEIR JOBS WERE
THEIR ASSISTANT MANAGERS AT A
PIZZERIA.
THIS IS THIS THAT AN ONGOING
SORT OF.
PICTURE OF THE FAMILIES THAT WE
SERVE THAT NEED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN OUR COMMUNITIES NOT
JUST HERE IN SACRAMENTO BUT
ACROSS OUR STATE.
AND THE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
NOT JUST A CRISIS FOR THIS
FAMILY IT'S AN EPIDEMIC ACROSS
OUR STATE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
.
WE MOST RECENTLY SAW THAT.
THAT ONE HALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS SPEND MORE THAN
THIRTY PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME
ON RENT AND ONE THIRD OF ALL
HOUSEHOLDS IN CALIFORNIA SPEND
MORE THAN FIFTY PERCENT.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP PROVIDE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR.
INCREASED CAPACITY WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND BRINGING
AND PARTNERS TO HELP CLOSE THAT
GAP. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
BEING ABLE TO PARTNER WITH YOU
IN ORDER TO HELP MAKE THAT
POSSIBLE.
HOLLY FOR MANY WITH WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF A
HABITAT FOR MANY CALIFORNIAN I'M
JUST HERE FOR ON TECHNICAL
SUPPORT OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IS.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE.
BUT QUIRK.
SO FOR HABITAT FOR HUMANITY YOU
HAVE A WONDERFUL PROGRAM.
AND.
YOU ARE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT HOW
MUCH PEOPLE CAN PAY. AND.
.
YOU ALSO HAVE RIGHT OF FIRST
REFUSAL FOR.
ONCE THE MORTGAGE IS GONE OUT
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THIS.
MONEY COULD GO TO PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE THOSE.
GUARANTEES AND I THINK WE WOULD
BE BETTER OFF SIMPLY PUTTING THE
MONEY IN THE BUDGET MAKING SURE
IT GOES TO GOOD ACTORS. LIKE.
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY THAT'S MY
CONCERN.
I'M I THINK I'M NOT SURE I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND QUESTION
BUT THE WAY THE I'M BILL IS
WRITTEN IS THAT IT IT IT WILL GO
TOWARDS THE NONPROFIT THAT ARE.
THE GOOD ACTORS THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT HAVE THAT. AND WE HAVE THE
FIVE A TWENTY THREE STATUS.
AND CHARITABLE STATUS.
IT'S WELL FEDERAL PROVIDING
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND JUST FOR THE
THIRTY TO PRETTY EIGHTY PERCENT
OF THE AM I.
WELL. THE THE POINT HERE IS
THOUGH THAT. IF YOU HAVE A
DIRECT GRANT PROGRAM.
STATE HAS MORE CONTROL ABOUT WHO
WOULD GOES TO WHEN THEY CAN GO
TO THE BETTER ACTOR.
AND AND THAT'S A CONCERN I.
I ALMOST NEVER VOTE FOR ANYTHING
IN THIS COMMITTEE SORRY. WELL I
I THINK ONE OF THAT. WITHOUT OF
LOOK AT THEM LOOKING AT THE CUT
CAUCUS CONSULTANT BUT I THINK
THERE WERE SOME FOLKS HAVE.
IN OUR WHAT COURSE FOR SUPPORT
OF THE GRANT PROGRAM THAT.
THE WAY THIS BILL IS SET UP AS
TO WHERE IT'S FIFTY PERCENT
CREDIT SO IT'LL ACTUALLY BE MORE
LEVERAGE ABLE PRIVATE DOLLARS.
WITH THE MATCH OF THE STATE
INSTEAD OF IT BEING A HUNDRED
PERCENT SO ACTUALLY
THEORETICALLY IT WILL BRING MORE
MONEY INTO ARE PROJECTS. THAN IT
WOULD IF IT WERE GRANT PROGRAM
BECAUSE OF THE MATCH
OKAY WELL LET ME KNOW GETTING
MORE MONEY FOR PROJECTS THAT IF
IT WERE JUST A DIRECT GRANT
PROGRAM. OKAY WELL LET'S GOOD
ANSWER TO MY QUESTION THANK YOU.
WELL WE HAVE A QUORUM WOULD LIKE
TO CALL THE ROLL.
BURKE HERE.
BRO HERE.
BONTA CHIU.
GRAY HAIR.
MCCARTY.
LANDIS
MULLIN.
QUIRK.
HERE.
VOEPEL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SIMPSON WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE SIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE. UP TODAY AND
SUPPORTS.
WE'VE CERTAINLY REQUEST FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND RECEIVE
NO OPPOSITION AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND IS
I'M GOING TO CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PROCESS
AMENDED TO THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE.
BURKE AYE BURKE AYE RO. RO I
BONTA CHIU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S LINDA'S
AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE VOEPEL.
SO I THANK YOU THAT BILLS OUT
NINE ZERO THANK YOU.
I RETURNING RETURNING A FILE
ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY THIRTY
THREE.
MR PEROT MOVES ANY A SECOND.
AND IN A SECOND FILE ITEM FIVE
ANY A SECOND CIRCUIT.
CHIU SECOND.
KILEY KALRA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
FOR.
BURKE I RURAL. ROW AYE BONTA
CHIU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
RAY I MCCARTY.
PRETTY AYE MULLIN JUST.
LINDA'S AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
QUIRK.
CAINE. WORK NOT VOTING.
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE EIGHT. THAT BILL IS
OUT EIGHT ZERO MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE MISTER PERRIN WOULD LIKE TO
OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES I COME
BEFORE YOU TODAY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE THE BILL
TO MODERNIZE THE SHARING OF
INFORMATION BETWEEN ASSESSORS
AND TAXPAYERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
THINKING COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE THOROUGH ANALYSIS IN FOR
FACILITATING CONVERSATIONS THAT
WILL MAKE THIS BILL MUCH BETTER.
ACCORDINGLY I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
FIVE AND TOP OF PAGE SIX.
INCREASINGLY DOCUMENTS CAN BE
PROVIDED BY ASSESSORS AND
TAXPAYERS BY A MORE EFFICIENT
AND COST EFFECTIVE MEANS BY MAIL
AND IN SOME INSTANCES ELECTRONIC
SHARING MAY BE AN OPTION.
UNFORTUNATELY EXISTING LAWS
WOEFULLY OUT OF DATE. AS MY
COUNTY ASSESSOR LARRY STONE CAN
SHARE THERE BEEN TIMES WHEN HIS
STAFF HAS UNNECESSARILY BEEN
FORCED TO TRAVEL TO VARIOUS
LOCATIONS AROUND THE STATE. TO
OBTAIN THE INFORMATION NECESSARY
TO DO HIS JOB.
AS AMENDED IT THIS BILL WILL
CODIFY THE EXISTING PRACTICE OF
TRANSMITTING INFORMATION VIA THE
MAIL AS WELL AS ALLOW FOR THE
RECIPROCAL RIGHT FOR ASSESSORS
AND TAXPAYERS TO RECEIVE
INFORMATION WHEN IT IS AVAILABLE
IN ELECTRONIC FORMAT.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THAT WE
SHOULD EMBRACE TECHNOLOGY AS A
MEANS OF INCREASING GOVERNMENT
EFFICIENCY.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE WOULD
ACCOMPLISH AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN WITH ME
TODAY IS A LARRY STONE ASSESSOR
SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
THANK YOU.
I'M LARRY STONE I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSESSORS ASSOCIATION AND IN MY
CAPACITY AS A SANTA CLARA COUNTY
ASSESSOR.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE DOES
ONE THING.
ONLY ONE THING.
IT ALLOWS FOR THE ELECTRONIC
TRANSMISSION OF DOCUMENTS
BETWEEN A TAXPAYER AND THE
ASSESSOR.
IT ISN'T THAT SIMPLE.
IN ORDER TO RENDER A FAIR AND
ACCURATE ASSESSMENT OF
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY ASSESSORS
NEED TO HAVE. AND HAVE THE LEGAL
RIGHT TO REQUEST AND RECEIVE
BASIC INFORMATION SUCH AS RENTS
VACANCIES INVOICES AND SO FORTH.
ALL OF THIS IS HELD IN STRICT
CONFIDENCE.
CURRENTLY THE LAW WRITTEN
DECADES AGO BEFORE THE INTERNET
AND EMAIL SPECIFIES ONLY ONE
METHOD. TRAVELLING TO A
TAXPAYERS PLACE OF BUSINESS.
CLEARLY IT'S IT'S IT'S EXPENSIVE
AND VERY INEFFICIENT FOR
APPRAISERS IN AUDITOR'S TO
TRAVEL TO A CORPORATION'S
HEADQUARTERS.
FREQUENTLY OUT OF STATE SUCH AS
IBM IN NEW YORK.
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES IN TEXAS
TO RECEIVE IMPORTANT INFORMATION
NECESSARY FOR A FAIR AND
EQUITABLE ASSESSMENT WHEN THIS
SAME INFORMATION IS READILY
AVAILABLE AND CAN BE TRANSMITTED
ELECTRONICALLY.
MODERNIZING OUR OUR QUE CODE IS
SIMPLY ABOUT EFFICIENT
GOVERNMENT NOTHING MORE.
ASSESSORS HAVE WORKED CLOSELY
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. AND
CAL TAX
A CLARIFYING IMPROVE THE BILL
FOR EXAMPLE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAS AGREED TO TAKE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED BY CAL TAX
WHICH WILL ALLOW THE
TRANSMISSION OF. DOCUMENTS FROM
A TAXPAYER TOO ASSESSOR AND.
AND FROM THE ASSESSOR TO A
TAXPAYER.
A TWO WAY STREET.
FAIR ENOUGH.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
ALLOWS FOR THE ELECTRONIC
TRANSMISSION OF INFORMATION AND
DOCUMENTS ONLY. UNDERSCORE ONLY
WHEN THEY ARE AVAILABLE IN
ELECTRONIC FORMAT.
IF IT'S NOT AVAILABLE FROM THE
TAXPAYERS TAXPAYERS CAN USE U.
S. MAIL OR PRIVATE DELIVERY
SERVICES SUCH AS FED EX AND UPS
WERE NOT IN EXISTENCE WHEN THE
CODE WAS WRITTEN DECADES AGO.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE HAS
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE INTERESTED PARTIES PROCESS
THAT'S CURRENTLY GOING ON AT THE
BE.
WE.
NOTHING ELSE CHANGES BUT THAT
THE ABILITY TO TRANSMIT
DOCUMENTS AND INFORMATION
ELECTRONICALLY.
BECAUSE PROPERTY TAXES ARE THE
BACKBONE OF FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES I
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT A.
B..
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE.
THINK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING I HOPE YOU COME.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PREY ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA LINES OF TAXPAYER
ADVOCATES. ARE RATHER THAN
TAKING UP THE COMMITTEE'S TIME
WITH MY TESTIMONY.
THE.
TWO MEMBERS OF KATO WILL BE
TESTIFYING AND LET'S START OFF
WITH THEIR SHAUN KEEGAN WHO IS
THE CHAIR OF KATO.
THANK YOU MARK.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME SHAUN KEEGAN
AMIS ACTIVE VICE PRESIDENT
PRINCIPLE OF PROPERTY TAX ASSIST
COMPANY.
I'M ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LINES OF TAXPAYER
ADVOCATES OF THE ACRONYM IS
KATE.
KATE IS A NONPROFIT TRADE
ASSOCIATION MADE OF TAX
CONSULTANTS AND OTHER
PROFESSIONALS.
REPRESENTING TAXPAYERS BEFORE
COUNTY ASSESSOR'S.
COUNTY ASSESSMENT APPEALS BOARD
AND THE STATE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION.
KATE IS PURPOSE IS TO PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIA
PROPERTY TAXPAYERS.
THAT'S ONE OF THE MANY REASONS
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY.
CAN'T BELIEVE THE COUNTY
ASSESSOR SHOULD HAVE THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO MAKE
FAIR AND ACCURATE ASSESSMENTS.
NO DISAGREEMENT THERE.
WELL THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
CORRECTLY ADDRESSED ISSUE OF
INFORMATION REQUEST.
RECIPROCITY.
IT DID NOT ADDRESS ANY OF THE
OTHER ISSUES WE RAISE OUR MARCH
THIRTIETH LETTER.
WHAT WE OBJECT TO OUR
INFORMATION REQUEST THAT ARE SO
OVERLY BROAD?
AN UNREASONABLE THAT THE
TAXPAYER CANNOT SATISFY THE
INFORMATION REQUESTS.
WERE SO BURDENSOME.
THE TAXPAYER GIVES UP ITS APPEAL
RENTS UP SO FRUSTRATED.
IN HAVING A HEARING BEFORE THIS
US APPEALS BOARD DENIED OR
DELAYED FOR A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME.
WE HAVE EXAMPLES WHERE THESE
LETTERS.
HAVE NUMEROUS REQUESTS FOR
INFORMATION.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS REQUESTED.
THERE'S NOTHING IN AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE OR THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE.
ACTUALLY AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE MASQUERADES.
AS A FIX OUR MODERNIZATION.
YOU PUT YOUR FINGER ON PAGE FIVE
F..
FOR INSTANCE.
IT HAS BEEN EVEN PUT IN THE
PAPERWORK THAT IT. FOR FORTY ONE
QUE.
ACTUALLY TALKS ABOUT THE
SUBMISSION OF INFORMATION IN
ELECTRONIC FORMAT.
IT'S ALREADY THERE.
HOWEVER AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE BECOMES EFFECTIVE OR IF
THESE CHANGES GO THROUGH WE'RE
GONNA CHANGE THREE OTHER CODE
SECTIONS THAT AFFECT THE
TAXPAYER.
AND THERE PROTECTIONS.
SO HOW DID WE GET HERE
FIRST IT'S IMPORTANT REMEMBER.
THAT IN ANY DISPUTE.
WITH THE COUNTY ASSESSOR THE
TAXPAYER HAS THE BURDEN OF
PROOF.
THEY HAVE TO SHOW TWO THINGS.
ASSESSORS PROPERTY TAX
ASSESSMENT IS INCORRECT OR
WRONG.
THAT THE TAXPAYERS OPINION OF
THE FAIR MARKET VALUE IS CORRECT
WHICH IS THE SECOND ITEM THEY
HAVE TO PROVE.
FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS KITA
ORGANIZATIONS URGE COUNTY
ASSESSORS INDIVIDUALLY. AND
COLLECTIVELY TO STOP THREATENING
TAXPAYERS WITH CRIMINAL.
AND CIVIL.
SANCTIONS.
ON THE FIRST REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION ON THE FIRST REQUEST
FOR INFORMATION
AFTER ASSESSMENT IN MOST CASES
WAS ALREADY MAY.
WE'RE PLEASED THAT SINCE THE END
OF LAST YEAR THE ASSESSORS
CALIFORNIA SUCH ASSOCIATION.
HAVE SEE SUCH PRACTICE
THEY POLICE THEIR OWN.
WE'VE ACTUALLY CHANGE LETTERS.
THE REAL ISSUE IS THAT THE
COUNTY ASSESSOR'S ON THE
ASSESSMENT PEELS BOARD. OR
VIOLATING THE TAXPAYERS DUE
PROCESS BY UNREASONABLY DELAYING
OR DENYING A HEARING BEFORE THE
ASSESSMENT PEELS BOARD.
UNTIL ALL THIS INFORMATION IS
PRODUCED.
THEREFORE THERE'S NO STATUTORY
RIGHT TO AND RECENTLY DELAY OR
DENY HEARING BEFORE THE
ASSESSMENT FEELS FOR.
THAT HAS BEEN CATERS FOCUS ALL
ALONG.
THE TOPIC WAS DISCUSSED FOR OVER
FOUR HOURS LAST WEEK AND FOUR.
WITH THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
INTERESTED PARTY MEETING.
WHAT WAS CLEAR IS THAT OTHER
THAN GOING TO COURT THERE'S NO
SIMPLE WAY FOR TAXPAYERS
CHALLENGE? ASSESSORS OVERLY
BROAD OR RUN REASONABLE REQUESTS
FOR INFORMATION.
ACCORDING TO THE BEAT WE REPORT
ON WORKLOADS AND ASSESSMENT
PEELS ACTIVITIES AND CALIFORNIA.
TWO DOZEN FIFTEEN TO SIXTEEN.
HUNDRED TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
APPEALS WERE FILED.
THIRTY NINE PERCENT OF THOSE
WERE WITHDRAWN FOR REASONS
UNKNOWN.
IT IS ARE EXPERIENCE AS A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER THESE APPEALS
FOR WITH PARTICULARLY BY SMALL
BUSINESSMEN.
BECAUSE THE INFORMATION REQUESTS
ARE OVERLY BROAD AND REASONABLE
RATHER THAN FIGHT THE ASSESSOR
THEY JUST GAVE UP. SO IT'S ONLY
THE REGULATION OR STATUTE.
THERE IS AN EFFICIENT WAY FOR
TAXPAYERS TO CHALLENGE THESE
ASSESSORS OVERLY BROAD AND
REASON REQUEST FOR INFORMATION.
WE THEREFORE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU. VOTE NO ON AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE AND
THANK YOU FOR THE EXTRA TIME
MINIATURE.
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND CHAIRMAN.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS MIKE MIDDLETON AND I
AM THE PRESIDENT OF PROTECTS
LLC.
HAVE ALSO BEEN A MEMBER OF KATO
FOR THE PAST SEVEN YEARS AND AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF CADIZ STANDARDS
COMMITTEE.
PRO TAX LLC HAS BEEN IN BUSINESS
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY. AND WE
REPRESENT TAXPAYERS IN NEARLY
EVERY COUNTY WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OUR FIRM HAS FILED APPROXIMATELY
FOUR THOUSAND FORMAL APPEAL
APPLICATIONS ANNUALLY OVER THE
PAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
THE MAJORITY OF OUR CLIENTS
INCLUDE SMALL TO MEDIUM SIZE
BUSINESS OWNERS.
OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE REALIZED
THAT THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
OBSTACLE FACING MANY OF THESE
TAXPAYERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
IS THAT OF DUE PROCESS.
IN OTHER WORDS WHO CONTROLS AT
TAXPAYERS ACCESS TO RECEIVE A
TIMELY HEARING BEFORE AN
ASSESSMENT APPEALS BOARD.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
PROVIDES TWO RATHER SIMPLE BUT
HIGHLY SIGNIFICANT CHANGES THAT
WILL RESTRICT A TAXPAYERS RIGHT
TO A TIMELY ASSESSMENT APPEAL
HEARING.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
IT'S TO ADD LANGUAGE UNDER
SECTION FOUR FORTY ONE D. THAT
WOULD NOW REQUIRE AN APPLICANT
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION REQUESTED
BY THE ASSESSOR. VIA MAIL OR
ELECTRONIC TRANSMISSION.
ALTHOUGH MANY APPLICANTS DO SO
AND IT'S IN THEIR BEST INTEREST
TO DO SO IN ORDER TO RECEIVE A
REDUCTION THERE IS NO SUCH
REQUIREMENT THAT EXISTS TODAY.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT TO SECTION
FOUR SEVENTY SIX TO STRIKE THE
LANGUAGE THAT PROVIDES ONLY THAT
THE APPLICANT SHALL MAKE THE
DOCUMENTS AVAILABLE TO THE
ASSESSOR FOR INSPECTION AT HIS
OR HER PRINCIPAL PLACE OF
BUSINESS.
AT FIRST GLANCE THESE CHANGES
MAY APPEAR TO BE MINOR AND VERY
REASONABLE.
HOWEVER THESE TWO CHANGES
STRATEGICALLY CHANGE THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT THAT TAXPAYERS
CURRENTLY HAVE TO RECEIVE A
TIMELY HEARING ON THE VALUATION
OF THE PROPERTY.
THE AMENDMENT ALTERS THE
EXISTING NARRATIVE AND THE
ASSESSOR AND OR THE ASSESSMENT
APPEALS BOARD ARE GIVEN CONTROL
REGARDING ACCESS OF ATTACK FOR
TAXPAYER TO A TIMELY HEARING.
THE TAXPAYER MAY BE REQUIRED TO
ATTEND MULTIPLE HEARINGS SIMPLY
TO DETERMINE IF THEY HAVE
COMPLIED WITH ALL OF THE
INFORMATION BEING REQUESTED FROM
THE ASSESSOR WHICH IS COST
PROHIBITIVE. AND MANY TAXPAYERS
SIMPLY GIVE UP.
ONCE AN APPEAL WAS FILED THE
ASSESSOR HAS ALREADY BEEN
PRESUMED TO HAVE VALUE THE
PROPERTY CORRECTLY AND IN ALMOST
EVERY CASE HAS RECEIVED A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION FROM EACH PROPERTY
OWNER. REGARDING THE PROPERTY
AND ITS DATA.
THE BURDEN NOW IS ON THE
TAXPAYER TO FIRST PROVIDE
EVIDENCE THAT THE ASSESSOR'S
VALUES INCORRECT.
IT'S SECOND TO PROVIDE EVIDENCE
OF THE ACTUAL FOR MARKET VALUE
OF THEIR PROPERTY.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE AS AN
ADDITIONAL AN UNREASONABLE
BURDEN ON THE TAXPAYER TO COMPLY
WITH IN A SUCH A REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. BEFORE
THE TAXPAYER IS EVEN ENTITLED TO
RECEIVE A TIMELY HEARING ON THE
VALUE QUESTION.
THIS AMENDMENT OR THIS. AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE WOULD
ONLY CODIFY THE PROBLEM THE CAT
A REYES WITH THE STATE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION NEARLY TWO YEARS
AGO. REGARDING THE DUE PROCESS
CHALLENGES THAT MANY SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS FACE TODAY.
WE THEREFORE MUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON
ASSESSORS BILL TWENTY AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THAT AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS KATE BALLOT BEHALF OF
RYAN LLC AND WOULD LIKE TO OUR
SOULS PREVIOUS COME.
IF YOU.
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MR MON.
THEY RAPTURED TRYING TO.
.
GET MY HANDS AROUND THE
OBJECTION HERE SO. TO ME THIS IS
A FAIRLY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY AND EASE
OF COMPLIANCE KIND OF A THING
YOU'RE SUGGESTING THAT.
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE LANGUAGE
IS WRITTEN IT'S ACTUALLY GOING
TO SLOW DOWN THE ASSESSMENT
APPEALS.
PROCESS TO BE THAT I'M HEARING
LOTS OF CONCERNS WITH THE
OVERALL PROCESS WHICH TO ME JUST
ON THE FACE OF IT FEELS LIKE IT
GOES BEYOND THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
YOU MAY HAVE SOME LARGER ISSUES
ABOUT.
THE ASSESSMENT APPEALS PROCESS
WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT BE OVERLY
BURDENSOME BUT BUT I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM HERE TODAY. FROM A FROM.
JUST AT THAT READ OF THE BILL
IT SEEMS LIKE THIS IS FAIRLY
STRAIGHTFORWARD I GUESS.
MADAM CHAIR WOULD WITH YOUR
PERMISSION IF IF WE ALLOW. OF
THE SPONSOR OR THE AUTHOR JUST
TO TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE OF OF
TIMELINESS.
I DON'T FEEL GREAT ABOUT
SLOWING THAT PROCESS DOWN BUT IF
THIS IS GOING TO ACTUALLY. A
MAKE GOVERNMENT MORE EFFICIENT.
ALL CERTAINLY FEEL BETTER
CASTING MY AYE VOTE. WHICH I.
PROBABLY WILL ANYWAY BUT.
MR TENNIS CLARA COUNTY ONLY FIVE
PERCENT OF ALL ASSESSMENT
APPEALS FILED ACTUALLY END UP.
AN INFORMAL HEARING THIS IS NOT
A MAJOR PROBLEM WITH MOST
TAXPAYERS.
I ASSESS SOME OF THE MAJOR
CORPORATIONS IN THE WORLD AND
FOR IN FACT THE NUMBER ONE
CORPORATION IN THE NUMBER TWO
CORE. OPPRESSION WE DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT IT'S. NOTHING
THAT THEY USE VIRTUALLY NOTHING
THAT THEY SAID IT HAS TO DO WITH
THIS BILL IT IS SIMPLE. WHETHER
IN FACT YOU TRANSMIT.
INFORMATION.
ELECTRONICALLY OR NOT IN THE
CODE ONLY LONELY PROVIDES AND IT
SEEMS TO ME IF I HAVE TO GO TO
NEW YORK OR TEXAS.
THAT WILL LENGTHEN.
THE PROCESS OF ARRIVING AT ITS
HEAD HADN'T HAD A QUICK VALUE IN
AN. ACCURATE ASSESSMENT.
.
YOUR STAFF LEXIE GET ON A PLANE
AND GO TO NEW YORK TO GET A
DOCUMENT EVERY YEAR I SEND.
.
AUDITOR'S.
CHICAGO NEW YORK DALLAS.
NO.
MIAMI PLACES THAT WE HAVE TO DO
AN AUDIT WELL IF SOMEBODY SAYS
TO ME IF YOU WANT TO SEE. THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU THEREAFTER
LEGALLY.
ENTITLED TO HAVE WHICH.
THEY INDICATED THEY ARE YOU CAN
ONLY YOU ONLY MUST COME TO OUR
BUSINESS IF WE DECIDE THAT WE'RE
SAYING.
TRANSMITTED ELECTRONICALLY MOST
COMPANIES DO ENOUGH HIM WITH A
SMALL COMPANY IF THE ELECTRONIC.
ACCESS DOESN'T EXIST THEN THEY
CAN MAIL IT.
OR. OR.
USE NO FED EX SIR. UPS OR
SOMETHING OF THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT MOST ALL
COMPANIES DO IT SURPRISES US
THAT.
THESE PEOPLE WANT TO.
WANT TO DELAY THE PROCESS.
THERE IS A LAW THAT ALL
ASSESSMENT APPEALS MUST BE
RESOLVED WITHIN A TWO YEAR
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
OR THE TAXPAYERS OPINION OF
VALUE AS STATED ON THE
ASSESSMENT APPEALS FORM.
HOLES SO THE LONGER IT CAN BE
DRAGGED OUT THE MORE LIKELY IT
IS WITH SOME COUNTIES NOT MY OWN
BUT SOME COUNTIES.
THAT THAT STATUTE WILL RUN IN
THE TAXPAYERS OPINION A VALUABLE
HOLE.
ASSESSORS ARE VERY INTERESTED IN
CLEARING ASSESSMENT APPEALS AS
FAST AS WE CAN. NOT TO DELAY
ANYTHING.
AND THE TAXPAYERS SHOULD BE
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
TOO BECAUSE OFTENTIMES IT
INVOLVES A REFUND.
AND AND YOU DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
THE EASE OF TRANSMISSION OF
THESE DOCUMENTS WILL LEAD.
THE ASSESSOR'S OFFICE TO BE
REQUESTING MORE DOCUMENTS.
SINCE THERE IS IT'S IT'S IT'S
RELATIVELY EASY TO TRANSMIT
ELECTRONICALLY WILL WILL THE
SCOPE OF WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
IN TERMS OF INFORMATION. BROUGHT
IN BECAUSE OF THE.
THESE WERE CREATING WITH THIS
LEGISLATION.
THAT WOULD NOT BE.
OF INTEREST TO US WERE ONLY
INTERESTED INFORMATION THAT
ALLOWS US TO MAKE AN ACCURATE
ASSESSMENT. NO LESS AND NO MORE.
AND WE YOU KNOW A STANDARD
SHOPPING CENTER OFFICE BUILDINGS
WHAT DO YOU ASK FOR AS I
MENTIONED.
RENT ROLE VACANCIES EXPENSES ALL
THE THINGS. THAT MUST BE
PROVIDED.
BY THE TAXPAYER IN ORDER US TO
MAKE AN ACCURATE ASSESSMENT.
SO WHY WE WOULD ASK FOR MORE
THAN THAT MORE THAN IS WHAT'S
NECESSARY OBVIOUSLY IF I'M
AUDITING AND DEALING WITH AN
APPEAL FROM GOOGLE OR APPLE.
THERE'S A LOT MORE INFORMATION
REQUESTED
BY THE WAY BOTH OF THOSE
COMPANIES PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION ELECTRONICALLY AND I
THINK THEY WOULD BE INSULTED IF
WE ASK HIM TO DO ANYTHING ELSE.
MOVE THE BELL.
I GOT.
WE'RE GOING TO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I WONDER
IF.
WE CAN NOW GET
KIND OF A RESPONSE TO SOME OF
THE CLAIMS THAT WERE MADE JUST
SO. I'M CLEAR BECAUSE HE BROUGHT
UP SOME.
.
QUESTIONS HERE THAT.
NO I'M LEAVING ONE TO THE
OPPOSITION LIKE TO CLARIFY.
YES I WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND
THANK YOU.
SO TOM THE ENTIRE ISSUE HERE IS
THE ACCESS TO A HEARING.
SO IF THE ASSESSOR NOW CONTROLS
THE REQUESTED INFORMATION.
AND THAT AN APPLICANT DOESN'T
HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION THEY
BECOME NON COMPLIANT.
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE AN AGENDA OF
COMPLIANCE AND NONCOMPLIANCE
TAXPAYERS SO TAX MAYOR HAVE TO
MAY HAVE TO COME BACK TO THREE
AND FOUR TIMES. UNTIL THEY
PROVIDE ALL THE INFORMATION
REQUIRED FROM AN ASSESSOR JUST
TO GET EVALUATION HEARING.
THAT IS NOT DUE PROCESS AND MANY
OF OUR CLIENTS HAVE SIMPLY GIVEN
UP
I GIVE YOU A BRIEF EXAMPLE WE
RECENTLY HAD A REQUEST. FOR
INFORMATION WE PROVIDED I THINK
FOUR OF THE SIX ITEMS ON THE ON
THE REQUEST WE WERE STILL TOLD
WE WERE NON COMPLIANT.
NOW YOU HAVE MUST COME BACK FROM
THE NOT COMPLAINING HEARING
YOU'LL BE DENIED.
SO WHEN YOU'RE TALKING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS IF THEY HAVE TO
SHOW UP TWO AND THREE FOUR TIMES
FOR HEARINGS JUST TO DETERMINE
IF THEY'RE COMPLIANT BEFORE THEY
ACTUALLY GET EVALUATION HEARING.
YOU'RE GONNA SEE APPEALS GO TO
NOTHING AND A LOT OF UNHAPPY
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO LOSE DUE
PROCESS TO GET THEIR VALUE HURT
THIS IS NOT THE WAY IT'S WORKED
FOR THE LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN PRACTICING.
BUT FROM NOT NOT MUCH DIFFERENT
THAN WHEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
SAYS THAT SOUNDS LIKE A SYSTEMIC
PROBLEM NOT A PROBLEM ABOUT HOW
THAT INFORMATION HAS BEEN
DELIVER FOR THE LAST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS SO RIGHT NOW IT'S BEING
DELIVERED EITHER IN PERSON OR.
VIA MAIL THIS IS SAYING TWO
THINGS TO YOUR. POINT
THIS IS SAYING TWO THINGS TO BE
CLEAR WRITE THAT DOWN NOW THOSE
THAT INFORMATION CAN BE
DELIVERED ELECTRONICALLY. NOW IF
YOU CAN GET THE INFORMATION BACK
THIS DOESN'T CHANGE THAT. THAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW THE OTHER
THING IS THIS IS RECIPROCAL SO
WHEN YOU SAY THAT THE.
.
THAT THE CUSTOMER THE CLIENT
CANNOT GET THE INFORMATION THIS
IS RECIPROCAL SO IT GOES TO THE
ASSESSOR AND IT CAN COME BACK AS
WELL SO. I THINK WHAT YOUR WILL
MY IMPRESSION OF WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IN MY UNDERSTANDING OF
THE BILL THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN
FROM COMMITTEE STAFF AND FOR MY
OWN REVIEW IS THAT. WHAT YOU'RE
DISCUSSING IS A SYSTEMIC PROBLEM
NOT A PROBLEM WITH THIS ACTUAL
BILL ON THE ROUTE ON THE ABILITY
TO DELIVER THE THOSE DOCUMENTS
VIA ELECTRONIC DELIVERY SYSTEM
THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY BEING
BROUGHT UP AFTER KATO BRACED OUR
CONCERNS? HERE'S THE MAJOR
PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL THE WORD
REQUIRE.
IF IT APPLICANT IS NOW REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE WHATEVER LAUNDRY LIST
THE ASSESSOR COMES UP WITH
BEFORE THEIR RIGHT TO A HEARING.
TO PROCESS IS BEING DENIED.
MOST OF THE INFORMATION WE
ALREADY PROVIDE ELECTRONICALLY.
THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE WE ALMOST
PROVIDE ALL THE TIME THE
INFORMATION ELECTRONICALLY AND
TO BE FAIR TO SANTA CLARA COUNTY
WE WORK OUT MOST ASSESSMENTS.
WE'RE HERE TALKING ABOUT THE
RIGHTS OF A TAXPAYER AND IF YOU
MAKE THIS REQUIREMENT WHICH
ISN'T THERE NOW THAT THE
ASSESSOR.
KING ASKED FOR WHATEVER THEY
WANT AND THEN THE APPEAL CAN BE
PUT OFF BY THE APPEALS BOARD.
THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE WITHDRAW FROM
THE PROCESS.
THE ISSUE IS THOUGH IS THAT
YOU'RE TALKING. WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT CAN HAPPEN NOW IN
THE DELIVERY SYSTEM THE WAY THAT
THINGS CAN BE DELIVERED NOW I
THINK THAT'S WHERE. WHERE I AM I
NOT GETTING IT YOU CAN STILL
PEOPLE CAN STILL ACCORDING TO
THE MINUTES RESTORE ASSESSOR
ABILITY TO VIEW DOCUMENTS ON
SITE? THAT IS STILL POSSIBLE SO
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
NOTHING IN THE LIVER DOCUMENTS
THAT HAPPENS NOW YOU JUST
FINISHED SAYING FOR THE LAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. THE
ELECTRONIC DELIVERY OF THOSE
DOES NOT CHANGED THAT IT DOESN'T
CHANGE AYE DOESN'T SOLVE YOUR
PROBLEM I GET THAT. BUT IT
DOESN'T CREATE AN ADDITIONAL
PROBLEM IT ACTUALLY MAKES IT
HOPEFUL I WOULD IMAGINE MORE
EFFICIENT BECAUSE THEY CAN BE
DELIVERED. IN BOTH DIRECTIONS
RECIPROCALLY VIA ELECTRONIC.
I'M GONNA SEE IF ANYONE ON ELSE
ON THE COMMITTEE HAS A QUESTION
HOLD ON ANYONE ELSE ON THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
MISTER BROWN.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT COM.
AND I KNOW THE ANNOUNCER SAYS
AGO SO FOR NEXT WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO WORK WITH IT SOUNDS
LIKE JUST A REQUIRE A WORD HERE
NOW WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO WORK
THE OPPOSITION HAS A MOVE
FORWARD IN THE PROCESS. SO SO WE
HAVE WORKED A LOT WITH WITH THE
OPPONENTS KEITA IN THEIR
ADVOCATES IN AND I'M GRATEFUL
FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY AND I THINK
THE CHANGES THAT WE'VE MADE TO
MAKE THIS RECIPROCAL HAS MADE
THE BILL BETTER I I DON'T KNOW
I'M HAPPY TO KEEP ON TALKING
WITH THEM. I DON'T KNOW THAT I
CHANGE THE WORD REQUIRE AND FOR
A. CERTAIN REASON WHICH IS
BECAUSE WE SAY IF AVAILABLE.
AND SO WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR FOR
TAXPAYERS HAD TO PROVIDE
ANYTHING THAT THEY DON'T ALREADY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
ELECTRONICALLY BOTH.
IT THAT ON TWICE.
IN IN THE BILL IT'S SPECIFIC IN
THE AMENDMENTS THAT SPECIFICALLY
SAYS IF AVAILABLE I I THINK THAT
THAT WOULD THAT SATISFY THEIR
CONCERNS. NAM BUT HAPPY TO KEEP
THE CONVERSATION GOING WITH THEM
ABSOLUTELY AND FOR REVIEW FOR
THE AMENDMENTS OUT LET'S JUST GO
THURMOND QUICK NUMBER ONE IS
RESTORE ASSESSORS ABILITY TO
VIEW DOCUMENTS ON SITE.
TWO IS ESTABLISHED WORSE AT
RECIPROCITY BETWEEN ASSESSOR AND
TAXPAYER FOR DOCUMENT
TRANSMITTAL BY MAIL OR
ELECTRONICALLY IF AVAILABLE.
THREE ALLOW TAXPAYERS TO RECEIVE
AVAILABLE AT TRONIC DOCUMENTS
WITHOUT COST.
NOT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MADAM CHAIRMAN I MAKE A COMMENT
AND RESPONSE WHAT YOU WHAT YOU
NEED TO HAVE A QUESTION FROM. A
MEMBER.
THERE ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM
ANY OTHER MEMBERS.
NOW.
SORRY WITH THAT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
JUST.
IDEA THAT AS I MENTIONED THAT I
LIKE TO THINK IT AND AND THEIR
ADVOCATES I THINK THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
WE'VE MADE THE BILL BETTER AND
ADDRESSED FRANKLY WHAT I THOUGHT
WAS THEIR LARGEST CONCERN.
WHICH WAS RECIPROCITY.
AND AGAIN THEM AS MY COLLEAGUES.
ON ON THE COMMITTEE INCLUDING
YOU MADAM CHAIR HAVE MENTIONED
THIS IS A VERY NARROWLY SCOPED
BILL THAT'S MEANT TO PROVIDE
MORE EFFICIENCY TO GOVERNMENT
SERVICES AND HOW WE DO BUSINESS.
AYE NOTHING MORE NOTHING LESS.
AND I'D RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
WITHOUT THE RECOMMENDATION IS IS
TO PASS WITH AMENDED I WOULD
HOPE THAT WHATEVER LAST THINGS
THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO GET WORKED
OUT WITH THE OPPOSITION YOU GET
WORKED UP FOR THE FLOOR WITHOUT
LISTS HIGHLAND WE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BURKE AYE AYE BURKE AYE BURL.
RONA VOTING BONTA.
CHU. CHU AYE GRAY.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
LINDA SNOW MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
VOEPEL.
THE BILL NOW.
WHAT COLOR?
THAT BILLS ON CALL IT NEEDS ONE
MORE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THINK YOU.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
THREE THOUSAND.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS REGARDING A SUNSET OF
FIVE YEARS FOR THE EXEMPTION AND
THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENT ON PAGE
FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS AS AN
AUTHORS AMENDMENT.
AS AMENDED AB THREE THOUSAND
WOULD EXEMPT THE SALE OF
HYDROGEN FUEL FOR ZERO MISSION
FUEL CELL BLOCK LECTURE VEHICLES
FROM THE STATE AND LOCAL SALES
TAX. AND.
AND USE TAX FOR FIVE YEARS.
EARLIER THIS YEAR GOVERNOR BROWN
ISSUED EXECUTIVE ORDER BE FORTY
EIGHT FOURTEEN WHICH AMONG OTHER
THINGS CALLED FOR A NEW
AMBITIOUS TARGET OF FIVE MILLION
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES BY TWENTY
THIRTY.
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES LIKE
THEIR PLUGIN BATTERY
COUNTERPARTS ARE ZERO EMISSION
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES BUT
ARE POWERED BY HYDROGEN.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
HYDROGEN PRODUCING STATES WITH
ITS HYDROGEN FUEL CELL SUBJECT
TO THE SALES AND USE TAX.
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA'S TAXATION
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE FUELS IS
INCONSISTENT.
SECTION THIRTY A SIXTY THREE
FIFTY THREE OF THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION CODE COMPLETELY EXEMPTS
ELECTRICITY FROM THE STATE AND
LOCAL SALES AND USE TAX.
BY EXEMPTING HYDROGEN SOLD AS
TRANSPORTATION FUEL FROM THE
SALES AND USE TAX A. B. THREE
THOUSAND WILL EQUALLY TREAT THE
CONSUMERS OF TWO DIFFERENT ZEBRA
TECHNOLOGIES.
AB THREE THOUSAND WILL ENSURE
PARITY BETWEEN TAXATION OF
HYDROGEN HYDROGEN AND
ELECTRICITY ONE SOLD AS
TRANSPORTATION FUELS PER ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. IN DOING SO
CONSUMERS PURCHASING FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WILL BE
TREATED EQUALLY.
THE TEMPORARY REDUCTION IN THE
COST OF HYDROGEN FUEL EASE THE
TRANSITION FOR CONSUMERS INTO
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THOUSAND IS
DOCTOR SHANE STEPHENS FOUNDER
FIRST ELEMENT FUEL AND JACK ONE
BIRDS ALL A SENIOR ENGINEER WITH
TOYOTA I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DOCTOR SHANE STEPHENS A
FOUNDER OF FIRST ELEMENT FUEL.
OF FIRST LET ME SAY THAT.
ME IN MY COMPANY WE WE REALLY
SUPPORT THAT CALIFORNIA ZEV
POLICY AND AND GOALS IN THE
STATE MY COMPANY WOULD NOT EXIST
WHERE MORE FOR WHO IF IT WEREN'T
FOR THESE.
THE POLICIES OF CALIFORNIA. A
TO DATE WE'VE BUILT NINETEEN
HYDROGEN STATIONS IN THE STATE
WE HAVE TWELVE OR UNDER
DEVELOPMENT WE'VE COMPLETED OVER
A HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
SUCCESSFUL FILLS OF RETAIL FUEL
CELL CARS IN THE HANDS. OF
CUSTOMERS.
AND WE ESTIMATE THAT WE'VE
AVOIDED NEARLY TWENTY MILLION
POUNDS OF CO TWO EMISSIONS AS A
RESULT OF THOSE FILMS.
TO PUT THAT INTO CONTEXT THAT'S
THE EQUIVALENT OF PLANTING A
FOREST SEVENTY FIVE TIMES THE
SIZE OF DISNEYLAND.
SO WE'RE PROUD OF OF.
THE START THAT WE'VE GOT AND
WE'RE OFF TO A GOOD START WITH
ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND. FUEL CELL
CARS ON THE ROAD IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE NEED TO TRANSITION OUT
EARLY COMMERCIAL SCALE AND WHILE
WERE HAVING SOME EARLY SUCCESS
THERE ARE MANY CHALLENGES THAT
WE STILL FACE AND IT'S NOT A. A
SILVER BULLET THAT'S GOING TO BE
A SOLUTION IT'S REALLY THE
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF POLICIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE BELIEVE THIS EXEMPTION WOULD
BE CONSISTENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT OF ZEV
TECHNOLOGIES OTHER ARE TO USE OF
TECHNOLOGIES PLUG IN VEHICLES
AND HYDROGEN.
THIS WOULD PUT THEM ON PARITY
IN TERMS OF HOW THE CONSUMERS OF
THOSE VEHICLES ARE TAXED.
AND WOULD ALSO ADDRESS EIGHT
NEAR TERM CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE
OF A HIGHER PRICE OF HYDROGEN AT
THE PUMP TODAY COMPARED TO
GASOLINE IN CONVENTIONAL FUELS.
SO WE WANT TO PASS A LOWER COST
ON TO THE CONSUMER AT THE PUMP.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
QUESTIONS THAT WE HEAR FROM OUR
CUSTOMERS ARE WELL WHEN IS THE
PRICE GOING TO COME DOWN WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN MY LEASE RUNS OUT.
I'M THINKING OF BUYING THIS
VEHICLE RATHER THAN LEASING IT
BUT AS THE PRICE OF HYDROGEN
GONNA STAY HIGH. WE BELIEVE THIS
WILL HELP STIMULATE.
THE ZEV THIS HAVE CUSTOMER IN
THE GROWTH OF SOBS.
I'M FINE I JUST WANT TO CLOSE BY
SAYING THAT AS WE ACHIEVE EARLY
COMMERCIAL SCALE AND WE THINK
WE'LL BE ABLE TO DO THAT IN THE
TEN YEAR TIME FRAME.
WE CERTAINLY WANT TO COME BACK
AND THINK ABOUT HOW ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES THAT AND THE
FUELING OF THEM SHOULD BE
APPROPRIATELY TAX.
AND.
THAT'S WHY WE'VE.
I RECOMMENDED SUNSET DATE I
THINK YOU GUYS BROUGHT THAT DOWN
WILL BE TO FIVE YEARS WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF REVISITING THIS IN
THE FUTURE. NOW TURNED OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE JACQUI FROM TOYOTA.
GREAT THINGS HERE.
AB MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M MY NAME IS JACKIE
BIRDS ON I AM A SENIOR ENGINEER
WITH TOYOTA MOTOR NORTH AMERICA.
AND WE'RE PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGETS
LEGISLATION.
AS YOU KNOW TO IT IS STRONGLY
COMMITTED TO DOING OUR PART TO
HELP ME CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS
AND IMPORTANT GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION AND CLIMATE CHANGE
GOALS.
IN ADDITION TO OFFERING PLUG IN
HYBRIDS AND BATTERY BUDGET
VEHICLES WE ARE ALSO PROUD TO
HAVE BEEN FIRST TO THE MARKET
WITH ARE FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE THE MERE AYE.
FC VIS OUR FRIEND EXCELLENT
ALTERNATIVE TO GASOLINE POWERED
CARS AND ARE MORE CLOSELY
MATCHING THE U. S. MASS MARKET
NEEDS FOR VEHICLES THAT CAN BE
REFUELED QUICKLY. AND DRIVING
LONG DISTANCES.
FOR EXAMPLE THE MERE I CAN HAS A
RANGE OF THREE OR TWELVE MILES
AND CAN BE REFILLED IN A MATTER
OF MINUTES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WILL
HELP ACCELERATE SEVEN OPTION IN
TWO WAYS.
THE FIRST IS THAT IT WILL HELP
TO REDUCE THE COST OF RETAIL
HYDROGENS THE CONSUMER DURING
THE EARLY MARKET INTRODUCTION
YEARS. ONE RETAIL HYDROGEN COSTS
ARE ON NATURALLY HIGHER THAN
THEY WILL BE IN A FULLY
DEVELOPED MARKET.
REDUCING THE CONSUMERS COST OF
OWNERSHIP WILL HELP TO
ACCELERATE THIS ADOPTION.
SECOND IT WILL CREATE PARITY
BETWEEN TWO THAT TECHNOLOGIES IN
THE MARKETPLACE TODAY. PLUGIN
BATTERIES SECOND ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND HYDROGEN FUEL CELLS
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES.
CURRENTLY THE LOCK COMPLETELY
EXEMPTS ELECTRICITY FROM THE
STATE AND LOCAL SALES AND USE
TAX FOR PLUG IN BATTERY
ELECTRICS. WHILE RETAIL HYDROGEN
FUEL CELLS UNFAIRLY REMAIN
SUBJECT TO THE SALES AND USE
TAX.
AB THREE THOUSAND WILL REMEDY
THIS INCONSISTENT TREATMENT OF
FUELS FOR THESE TWO ELECTRIC
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE EMPLOY A
WIDE RANGE OF NEAR TERM TOOLS TO
ENCOURAGE AND ACCELERATE
CONSUMER ADOPTION IF WE ARE TO
ACHIEVE ARE IMPORTANT
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR CLIMATE
CHANGE SCHOOLS.
INDEED THEY ARE RESOURCES BOARD
HAS REPEATEDLY MADE CLEAR THAT
WE CANNOT ME ARM ABILITY TRAMPS
ARE MOBILE TRANSPORTATION
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS WITHOUT
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGY.
AS WELL AS OTHERS THAT
TECHNOLOGIES.
SO WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
AB THREE THOUSAND WILL SIMPLY
ENSURE PARITY BETWEEN THE
TAXATION OF HYDROGEN AND
ELECTRICITY ONE SOLD AS A
TRANSPORTATION FUEL FOR ZAPS.
AND IN DOING SO CONSUMER
PURCHASING FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES WILL BE TREATED
EQUALLY.
AND THE TEMPORARY REDUCTION IN
THE COST OF HYDROGEN WILL
ACCELERATE CONSUMER TRANSITION
INTO OF CVS.
WE THEREFORE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN WHITE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
BUSINESS COUNCIL WE SUPPORT THE
BILL.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS DIRECTLY JOHNSON
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES. EVEN OPPOSE MONTH
AMENDED POSITION ASKING THAT THE
GOALS OF THIS BILL ARE SHEEP
THERE A STATE SHARE EXEMPTION ON
THE LOCAL SHARE WHICH IS USED TO
FUND. I'M CRITICAL NINE.
BY NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT NOT TO MENTION LOCAL
PROGRAMS OFFERED BY COUNTY SO
FOR THOSE REASONS RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AMENDMENTS TO EXCLUDE
THE LOCAL SHARE FROM THE
EXEMPTION THANK YOU.
SOME OF THE CROW THE CALL FOR A
TAX REFORM ASSOCIATION WE
HAVEN'T TAKEN A POSITION ON THIS
BILL YET.
A WOULD MENTION THAT THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF BILLS LIKE THIS THAT
HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED OVER TIME
AND AND PERHAPS MAYBE. NOW
CERTAINLY.
I'VE I THINK MR PEROT HAD
UMBILICAL YEARS BACK REVISING
ONE THAT WAS.
CREATED THE YEAR OF MY BIRTH SO
WE HAVE A LOT OF THESE MEASURES
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE REALLY
STARTED CONSIDERING.
PUTTING SUNSET DATES AND SORT
OF MANDATING SUNSET DATES ON
THESE ITEMS AND SO THERE'S A
SLEW OF ITEMS INTENDED TO
INCENTIVIZE. VARIOUS FUELS AND
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE REALLY
VERY OUTDATED AT THIS POINT AND
YOU MIGHT CONSIDER LOOKING AT
SOME OF THOSE AS A WAY TO OFFSET
THE COSTS IN THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MISTER MELONES
MCCURRY.
WELL AND LOOK AT HIM.
JUST THAT CPAS GENERAL QUESTION
I SUPPORT THIS I THINK WE NEED
MORE.
.
WHEN WE DO THAT.
MORE POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
FOCUS ON SAID VEHICLES IT'S ONLY
ONE POINT FORWARD IT TO TWO
MILLION AND I GUESS THERE'S
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND THEIR
VEHICLES. PER THIS ANALYSIS OF
HOW MANY FUEL. HYDROGEN FUEL.
VEHICLES TO HAVE HERE COMPARED
TO. LET'S SAY YOU KNOW NON HUGS
INFILL.
IT WAS NOT THE SOLE HYBRIDS BUT
BY TAP PLUGINS.
WE ARE RISE SOLD OVER THREE
THOUSAND VEHICLES THE ONE AS
TOYOTA WITH OTHER AUTOMAKERS UP
OVER THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED. YEAH
SUCH A DROP IN THE BUCKET
COMPARED THE OVERALL AND DO YOU
THINK BY HAVING EXEMPTION ON
THAT SALES TAX THAT THIS WOULD
MAKE IT AT A DIFFERENCE FOR
CONSUMER BEHAVIOR.
ARE THERE OTHER FACTORS THAT ARE
THAT ARE WAY ABOVE THAT THE SALE
OF FUEL.
I THINK YES THAT THE YOU KNOW
THE SALES TAX IS A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION IT'S NEARLY TEN PERCENT
OF YOU LOOK AT THE AVERAGE
ACROSS ALL THE LOCATIONS THAT
WERE IN AND.
I THINK THAT.
IF WE CAN EVEN SHELVE THE
SIGNAL THAT THE PRICES STARTING
TO COME DOWN THAT WILL MAKE A
BIG DIFFERENCE TO US TO
CONSUMERS IN THIS NEAR TERM
MARKET.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ESCORT.
SO I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
FIGURING THIS OUT.
SO I ALMOST I ENDED UP GETTING
THE HONDA CLARITY FUEL CELL.
AND I USE THE TRIGGER ZERO
STATION.
ABA KIND OF BETA TESTERS HITS
TECHNOLOGY WELL YOUR STATIONS
ARE PRETTY GOOD.
AND LINDY STATIONS ARE AWFUL
ANYWAY.
SORRY ABOUT THAT IF THERE'S A
SOMEBODY FROM LINDA HERE BUT I
CAN DOCUMENT IT.
ANYWAY.
SO WE'RE KIND OF BETA TESTERS.
AND.
I WOULD APPRECIATE SOMETHING
THAT WOULD HELP US THE PROBLEM
IS THIS REALLY DOESN'T EVERYONE
WHO BUYS A CAR TODAY.
THE FUEL IS PAID FOR BY THE
MANUFACTURER WHETHER IT'S TOYOTA
OR HONDA OR ANYONE ELSE.
AND I WAS TOLD THAT.
NOT TOO EXPECT TO BE ABLE TO BY
THIS BECAUSE FRANKLY THE FUEL
CELL TECHNOLOGY IS PROBABLY
GONNA BE VERY DIFFERENT AT THE
END OF MY THREE YEAR LEASE.
AND TYPICALLY THESE HAVE THREE
YEAR LEASES WERE TALKING ABOUT.
A FIVE YEAR SUNSET AND NO ONE IS
PAINFUL NO CONSUMER IS PAYING
FOR HYDROGEN.
SO IT WOULD CLEARLY HELP.
EITHER THE MANUFACTURER WHO
WOULD BE PAYING TEN PERCENT
LAST.
OR THE RETAILER I'M NOT QUITE
SURE. WHETHER THE REACH WHETHER
YOU IS A RETAILER WOULD BE DO
SHARE PRICE TEN PERCENTER.
AND GIVE IT ON TO THE
MANUFACTURER WHETHER IT WOULD
JUST HELP YOUR BUSINESS. AND I'M
WILLING TO SAY YOU KNOW IF THE
MANUFACTURER THANKS.
THIS WOULD HELP THEM OR IF YOU
THINK YOU REALLY NEED THAT BOOST
YOUR PROFITS THAT'S FINE BUT I
JUST DON'T SEE HOW IT HELPS
CONSUMER.
.
SO.
LET ME WAY AND I'M SURE JACQUI
WILL KNOW ONE AWAY AS WELL SO I
THINK I'M. YOUR NUMBER ONE
THERE'S THIS THE SIGNAL THAT
THAT YOU SENT TO THE MARKET AND
RIGHT NOW. AUTOMAKERS ARE PAYING
FOR THE FUEL IS A NECESSARY EVIL
THEY DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO DO
THAT. THEY'RE DOING IT BECAUSE
IT FEELS UNNATURALLY RAY HOW
HIGH RIGHT NOW THE PRICES ARE
NATURALLY HIGH RIGHT NOW IN THE
EARLY MARKET.
WE'RE IN ON THE NEAR TERM
THAT'S GOOD FOR US BECAUSE IT
TAKES SOME OF THE PRESSURE OFF
OF MY COMPANY FOR LOWERING THE
PRICE. BUT THAT'S NOT HEY CREATE
A REAL MARKET RIGHT AND ITS
CUSTOMERS KEEP GETTING USED TO
THOUGH OEM'S THE AUTOMAKERS
PAYING FOR THE FUEL. I MEAN
THAT'S LIKE CRACK COCAINE YEAH
THEY'RE GONNA WANT TO KEEP THAT.
THAT HABIT GOING AND GOING AND
THAT'S NOT A WAY TO CREATE A
SUSTAINABLE LONG TERM MARKET. OF
THAT COST TO THE AUTOMAKERS WILL
BALLOON SO HIGH THAT. NOW THEY
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
THAT.
AND I THINK OUT NUMBER TWO
THERE IS A QUESTION OF US
CUSTOMERS GET INTO THIS IN THE
LONG TERM THEY'RE CONSIDERING.
DIE WANT TO BUY THIS CAR OR LEAD
SAFE AND I THINK WITH THE HONDA
LEASES THE ONLY OPTION THAT
THEY'RE GIVING BUT THE MIRAI YOU
CAN ACTUALLY BUY IT AS WELL. ARE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
DISSUADING CUSTOMERS FROM BUYING
THE CAR BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN THE PRICE
OF FUEL AND THEIR.
THEIR FEELS ONLY GETTING PAID
FOR FOR A THREE YEAR TIME PERIOD
SO NINE SO WOULD GO DOWN FROM
THE EQUIVALENT OF ABOUT EIGHT
DOLLARS A GALLON TWO SEVEN
TWENTY.
THAT'S ABOUT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT BECAUSE IT SIXTEEN DOLLARS
A KILOGRAM AND. ROUGHLY
KILOGRAMS WORTH YOU GET ABOUT
SIXTY MILES.
AND WE DO PLAN TO PASS THAT COST
ON TO THE CONSUMER WON'T. BE
IMPACTS OUR PROFIT FOR COMPANY.
SURE.
YES OKAY.
THANK YOU JUST QUIRK ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK.
SEEING NONE.
THERE WAS A MOTION WAS OUR
SECOND.
WAIT A SECOND.
SECULARIST MCCARTY.
ISRAEL JOINT CLOSE.
YOU HAVE DUBBED THIS IS YOU KNOW
ESSENTIALLY ABOUT PARITY ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE AN
EQUAL PLAYING FIELD FOR THESE
TWO TECHNOLOGIES THAT WERE NOT
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS. AND
I THINK WE ALL CAN TO THE
BENEFIT OF GETTING AS MNY OF
THESE DEPLOYED AS POSSIBLE.
AND WITHOUT I WOULD REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE RESPECTFULLY.
THANK YOU LET ME JUST READ THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE AGREED TO
BY THE AUTHOR ONE SHORTEN THE
SUNSET PERIOD FIVE YEARS TO
ADOPT TECHNICAL AMENDMENT NOTED
IN COMMENT.
I OF THE CAMINO HOUSES AND
THIRD AND TO SOME OF OUR TING IS
A CO AUTHOR. MADAM CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
WELL. GROW I BONTA CHIU.
CHIU ARE GRAY.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
MULLIN JUST NOT VOTING MULLIN.
QUIRK.
NOT VOTING WORK NOT VOTING
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
AND COOLEY
TELL CALL WE NEED TO MORE VOTES
AND I WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL OFTEN EXPECTING
FUTURE.
MOVING TO.
YEAH WE'RE GOING TO FILE ITEMS.
ONE AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE
MISTER JONES SAWYER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO OPEN.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
FIRST I WILL START BY ACCEPTING
DE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE. A.
B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE WILL
ALLOW CAMERAS BUSINESSES FILING
AS A SOLE PROPRIETOR OR
PARTNERSHIP OR LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANY TO DEDUCT ORDINARY AND
NECESSARY BUSINESS EXPENSES.
FROM THEIR PERSONAL INTIMATE
COME TAX
INCOME STATE TAXES.
THE ABILITY TO DEDUCT EXPENSES
INCURRED WHILE CONDUCTING
BUSINESS IS ENJOYED BY ALL
LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES WHEN
FILING TAXES
HOWEVER THE IRS CODE SECTION TWO
EIGHT ZERO.
E. PROHIBITS NOT CORPORATE
ENTITIES THAT DERIVE THEIR
PROFITS FROM THE TRAFFICKING OF
A CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE
FROM DEDUCTING THESE EXPENSES AS
A RESULT CAMERAS BUSINESSES THAT
ARE NOT INCORPORATED. ARE TAXED
AT HIGHER RATES THAN ANY OTHER
LEGAL BUSINESS IN THE STATE. AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE WILL ALLOW
THE CORPORATE AND THE PERSONAL
TAX CODES ALLOW LEGAL CANADA'S
BUSINESSES TO DEDUCT LEGITIMATE
OPERATIONAL EXPENSES.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE EMMA SO
SNUG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK A GUY
VOTE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT TODAY A MY NAME IS
EMMA SNAGS I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION OR SEE CA.
CCA HAS OVER FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
BUSINESS MEMBERS REPRESENTING
SIX HUNDRED CANNABIS BRANDS AND
NEARLY TEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
ACROSS THE STATE. SINCE
ASSOCIATION WAS FOUNDED ALMOST
FIVE YEARS AGO WE WORK
TIRELESSLY TO IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS
THAT ALLOW OUR MEMBERS TO BE
TREATED LIKE ANY OTHER LICENSE
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA.
DOES I SEE CA FULLY SUPPORTS THE
NEED TO REDUCE THE TAX BURDEN ON
LICENSE CANNABIS BUSINESSES. AND
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT SUCH
EFFORTS WILL REDUCE ILLICIT
OPERATIONS AND ENCOURAGE MORE
OPERATORS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
COMPLIANT MARKETPLACE.
WHITE HEARING TO THE MEDICINAL
ADULT USE CANNABIS REGULATION
AND SAFETY ACT OR MARKERS THAT.
I'M ENACTED LAST YEAR LICENSE
CANNABIS BUSINESSES ARE
CURRENTLY PAINT SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER TAXES AND FEES THAN THEIR
UNLICENSED COMPETITORS.
THE ABILITY FOR THESE BUSINESSES
TO DEDUCT THEIR BUSINESS
EXPENSES FROM THEIR GROSS INCOME
AS PROVIDED IN THIS BILL WILL
ENCOURAGE COMPLAINTS OF
CALIFORNIA'S NEW CANNABIS LAWS.
REDUCED RD SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANT TAX BURDEN ON LEGAL
BUSINESSES AND PROMOTE
REGULATION AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
FOR THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED WE'RE PLEASED TO SPONSOR
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY THREE AND
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT.
I KATHY VAN AUSTIN REPRESENTING
CMG KHALIFA. AND I'D CERTAINLY
ONE ECHO AND. OF HER EARLIER
COMMENTS.
ONE OF THE THE THINGS THAT YOU
REALLY RELY ON IT'S A BUSINESS
OWNER IS BEING ABLE TO DEDUCT
YOUR EXPENSES WHETHER IT'S FOR
CONSTRUCTION AND MAINTENANCE
EMPLOYEES EMPLOYEE TAXES.
AND YOUR LEAN OF WHAT THE WHAT
HAVE YOU THERE ARE NUMBER OF
EXPENSES THAT ARE. ANY BUSINESS
CAN TAKE AND TO DOC'S.
I NOT ONLY FROM THE FEDERAL BUT
THEY'RE HAVING.
AND IT IT COUNTS ORDER STATE
TAXES
I BELIEVE.
.
THIS BILL REALLY RECOGNIZES THE
DILEMMA THAT THIS.
THOSE PARTS THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY AND KHALIFAH IS ONE OF
LARGEST.
ENTITIES IN THE STATE THE
VERTICALLY INTEGRATED OUT OF SAN
JOSE.
AND THEIR EXPENSES AND AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE ARE IN THE MILLIONS
AT THE MULTI MILLIONS AND THEY
CANNOT DEDUCT A SINGLE.
PENNY.
SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE SPELL
AND WE THINK OF THE ASSEMBLYMAN
FOR FOR INTRODUCING AND BRING IT
FORWARD.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
EITHER KILL ANYONE BEHALF OF WE
DROPPED CANNABIS LIVINGIN THE
LONG BEACH COLLECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
REALLY PART MEASURE THINKING.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE TO MOVE THE
BILL.
ACTIONS OF COMICS
SEEING NONE.
WOOD MISTER RIGHT JONES SAWYER
WOULD YOU LIKE BECAUSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
THIS HIGHLY CULTURAL.
THEM EMMETT'S R. ADOPT THE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENT NOTED IN
THE COMMENTS SECTION HALF OF THE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES WHICH YOU
OPEN WHICH IS PRETTY TO WRITE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE
BURKE AYE GROW. GROW AYE BONTA.
CHIU.
CHIU I GRAY MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S EXCUSE ME.
MELINDA SNOW. MULLIN QUIRK AYE
QUIRK I'VE A FELL.
THAT'S ON COLLEGE NEEDS ONE.
THANK YOU.
LEVINE FILE ITEM TO AB TWENTY
THREE NINETY FOUR.
MISTER VICE CHAIR PRO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO OPEN
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF WORK
IN THE ON THIS. PIECE OF
LEGISLATION MAYBE TWENTY THREE
NINETY FOUR WILL EXAM UNIFORM
SERVICES TIME AND PAY FROM STATE
INCOME TAX FOR VETERANS WHO ARE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA.
SPILL ALSO HAS A TEN YEAR SUNSET
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION VETERANS ACCORDING
TO THE CALIFORNIA PLUMMET
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. FORTY
PERCENT OF VETERANS ARE ACTIVE
IN OUR LABOR FORCE.
OF ALL CALIFORNIA VETERANS ONLY
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX THOUSAND THESE
MEN AND WOMEN SERVE THE MEN ON
TWENTY YEARS SERVICE. TO RECEIVE
RETIREMENT BENEFITS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE MOST VETERANS RECEIVING
RETIREMENT PAYER IN THEIR
FORTIES PROVIDING VETERANS THESE
BENEFITS WILL INCENTIVIZE IN THE
START THEIR SECOND CAREERS HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHERE TECHNOLOGY HUB OF THE
WORLD IN MANY OF THESE VETERANS
ARE INTELLIGENCE OFFICERS WILL
HIGH APTITUDE FOR TECHNOLOGY?
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCE A SHORTAGE
OF HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS MANY
OF THESE VETERANS OF DOCTORS AND
NURSES WITH YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
ARE PROVIDING THESE TAX BENEFITS
FOR RETIRED VETERANS CALIFORNIA
WILL JOIN SIXTEEN OTHER STATES
LIKE NEW YORK. THAT OF STATE
INCOME TAX WILL PROVIDE THESE
EXEMPTIONS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVED OUR
COUNTRY. AND THIS BILL IS
ENCOURAGING VETERANS TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA AFTER THEY RETIRE AND
START THEIR SECOND CAREERS.
WOULD NEED TODAY TO SUPPORT.
.
THE BILL IS COLONEL LORNA GREECE
WITH CALIFORNIA MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
AND JIM LOUIS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL THE
NATIONAL GUARD ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME'S CORE LORNA GRIESHEIM
RETIRED FROM THE ARMY NURSE
CORPS. I REPRESENT MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF FORTY ONE CHAPTERS
OPEN DOWN THE STATE.
COMO MEMBERS ARE THE DOCTORS
ACCOUNTANTS BUSINESS
PROFESSIONALS LAWYERS DENNIS
NURSES ENGINEERS AND SO FORTH.
THE PEOPLE ARE MOST LIKELY TO
KEEP WORKING AT HIGH PAYING JOBS
AFTER THEY RETIRE FROM THE
MILITARY.
MANY OF MY PEERS AND CAL MORE
ARE LEAVING THE STATE. AND I'LL
TELL YOU BY WHEN I TELL YOU
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO ME.
WHEN I FIRST RETIRED I START
WORKING AS A NURSE BUT SOON
FOUND THEM MY NEW INCOME WAS
HEAVILY TAXED.
IT DIDN'T REALLY PAY ME TO WORK.
I LEFT NURSING FOR VOLUNTEER
WORK AND START MY OWN BUSINESS.
I CREATED AN ONLINE BUSINESS
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE MY ARTWORK
BOOK SALES AND WAS COVERED BY A
LIMITED LIABILITY CORPORATION.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WAS A
FIRST YEAR BY BUSINESS WAS
STARTING TO SHOW SOME.
INCOME UNTIL TAX TIME CAME.
WITH THE EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLAR
CORPORATE TAX NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO BUSINESS TAX BY WHICH
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
AND THE THOUSANDS ARE PAYING
INCOME TAXES.
.
FOR. WHATEVER INCOME I HAD WAS
PRETTY MUCH WIPED OUT FROM MY
BUSINESS.
I DO KNOW THAT WORK FOR NOTHING
I'M ALSO HOMEOWNER THE THREE
HUNDRED OR SO MONTHS I PAY IN
REAL ESTATE TAXES ADDS TO THE
BURDEN.
I HAPPEN ARMY RETIRED SALARY I
HAVE BORROWING POWER I SUPPORT
THE STATE WITH THE SALES TAXES
FROM THE THINGS I BY.
EXCEPT FOR THE FACT THAT I'M A
SECOND GENERATION NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN I HAVE NO IDEA WHILE
I'M STILL HERE.
MY BROTHER LEFT FOUR YEARS AGO.
LEAVING IS GIVING MORE
ATTRACTIVE.
KEEP THE RETIRED MILITARY PEOPLE
WITH BUYING POWER IN THE STATE.
I. ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL WILL GROW.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF NUMBERS
I'M JIM LET ME EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE.
PARCELLS HE'S
CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY MEMBERS THE NATIONAL
GUARD TO SERVE TWENTY YEARS TO
NOT RECEIVE THEIR RETIRED BUT
OFTEN SCINTILLA OF THE AGE OF
SIXTY.
SPILL OR.
WILL INCENTIVIZE THE THOSE
MEMBERS TO STAY IN CALIFORNIA
AND CONTINUE TO WORKING WHILE
THEY WAIT TO RECEIVE THEIR HARD
EARNED BENEFITS.
I'M IT AN EXAMPLE OF LOVE.
I'M RETIRED AND I'M STILL
WORKING IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE MOST
EXTENSIVE STAYS PRIVATE. AND
WERE AND RETIRED VETERANS WILL
MOVE OUT KNOWING THEY CAN GET A
BETTER DEAL SOMEWHERE ELSE.
IN RECENTLY HAVE TALKED TO
PEOPLE WAS OAKLAND POLICE
OFFICER HE JUST MOVED AFTER
RETIREMENT TO AND MILITARY
RETIREMENT. YOU THIS MOVE TO.
WHILE A NOTE TO A MONTANA.
ANOTHER ONE POSIES THAT.
THAT I TALK TO THEY MOVED TO.
ON NATIONAL TENNESSEE.
CALIFORNIA CLAIMS LEAD THE
NATION IN MANY POLICIES ISSUES
PROVIDING BENEFITS AND RETIRED
VETERANS IS NOT ONE OF THEM. AB
THREE TO A TWO THREE NINE FOUR
IS THE RIGHT STEP TO KEEP
VETERANS HERE AN ENTIRE FUTURE
VETERANS TO COME TO CALIFORNIA.
THE NATIONAL GUARD ASSOCIATION
OF SUPPORT AB THREE TWO THREE
NINE FOUR AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SET FREE WITH READ
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
REPRESENTING AMERICAN GI FORM OF
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA. AND VETS
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS.
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL. VIETNAM
VETERANS OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF CHAPTERS OWN SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MAY THE CROW
THE TALKS REFORM ASSOCIATION I'M
A COUPLE PROBLEMS WITH THIS BILL
AND YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN DECADES
SINCE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DID OFFER A BENEFIT OF THIS
NATURE TO VETERANS AND EVEN
THEN.
WE'RE TALK ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
WAS REALLY LIMITED TO A
SPECIFIC.
I AM. TO A SPECIFIC INCOME LEVEL
HERE YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY TALKING PER THE AUTHORS
ON COMMENTARY ABOUT PEOPLE WERE
VERY HIGHLY SKILLED WHO ARE WHO
ARE VERY LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY MAKE. UPWARDS OF A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
AND WE WILL STILL THEN BE
PROVIDING A TAX CREDIT UNDER
THIS BILL. TO THE TUNE OF TWO
HUNDRED OVER TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS. AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
ULTIMATELY IS GOING TO TAKE AWAY
FUNDING FROM THE GENERAL FUND
FOR OTHER OF OUR PUBLIC SERVANTS
POLICE FIRE AT CETERA OUGHT TO A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT DEGREE AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE THE
MEASURE THINKING.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE TALKED QUIRK.
YEAH I JUST THINK THIS MONEY
WOULD BE BETTER SPENT ON
SOMETHING LIKE HOMELESSNESS FOR
VETERANS WHICH IS A REALLY BIG
PROBLEM RIGHT NOW.
WELL WE PASSED THE BOND IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN HOW TO DRESS
HOMELESS VETERANS IN THE
COUNTIES ARE MY OWN COUNTY OF
ORANGES SAID NOT TO AND FOURTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROP SIXTY
THREE MONEY. SO THERE'S MONIES
AVAILABLE IT'S MORE OF A
MANAGEMENT PROBLEM. BUT.
RESPONDING TO THE OPPOSITION.
THERE'S NO MONEY TO COLLECT IF
THE RETIREE DOESN'T LIVE IN THE
STATE.
SO WE NEED INCENTIVES TO KEEP
THESE PEOPLE HERE. YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN COME FROM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY SERVE ON SHIPS IN SAN
DIEGO. MARINE SERVE ON CAMPAIGN
TOTAL PANEL TEN ON THE SOUTHERN
PART OF MY DISTRICT LOT OF ON
RETIRING SAN CLEMENTE.
FOR AWARD.
DE INTELLIGENCE.
AGENCIES UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND IF WE WANT THESE
PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS TO STAY IN
THE STATE WE NEED OFFER SOME.
SOME TAX CREDITS OR SOME
INCENTIVE FOR THOSE IN AND ITS
STATE IT'S NOT JUST VETERANS AND
STATE RETIREES AS WELL.
I MAKE A COMMENT.
A IF YOU'RE NOT AWARE.
VETERANS AND FEDERAL BENEFITS
BROUGHT IN OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
NEW FEDERAL BENEFITS. WHICH MOST
OF WILL CONTINUE TO COME AND AS
LONG AS I LIVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S A GREAT POINT AS WELL
THE WAY THE VA MODEL IS BASED.
IT'S BASED ON POPULATION SO OF
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE VETERANS THE
VA'S FORCED TO BUILD MORE
CLINICS IN MORE HOSPITALS AND
PUT MORE RESOURCES
IN THE STATE IF WE HAVE LESS
VETERANS. THE VA WILL SPEND REST
LESS RESOURCES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OTHER QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NO WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
JUST.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP ON THIS
BILL RESPECT LASHER OTHER.
AND. I WANNA THANK YOU MISTER
REFRAIN ATTAIN YOUR SON SAID.
AND OBVIOUSLY CALIFORNIA. IS
ONLY IN ONE OF ONLY NINE STATES
TO FULLY TAX CENTER. MILITARY
RETIREMENT PAY AND WE REALLY
SHOULD BE TRYING TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA MORE FRIENDLY STATE
FOR A MILITARY SO. WITH THAT WE
HAVE THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS MISSILE
AND COLOR OF. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE FIVE PEARL I'M.
ROLL AYE BONTA CHIU.
CHIU I GRAY MCCARTY.
CORDY I MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S I MULLIN QUIRK. ABOUT
WORK NOT VOTING VOEPEL.
THE PUBLIC.
THAT DOES OUT THEY CAN THANK
YOU.
I'M LIVING A FILE ITEM EIGHT OUR
LAST BILL AB THREE ZERO ZERO
NINE. MISTER DOCTOR QUIRK WOULD
YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
THOUSANDS.
ALRIGHT FIRST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOUR CHAIR AND STAFF FOR.
THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THEM.
ARE AB THREE ZERO ZERO NINE
WOULD ENACT A ONE DOLLAR PER
GALLON.
FEE ON PAINT MANUFACTURERS FOR
ALL PAINT SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
THE MONEY FROM THE FEE WOULD GO
TO CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT
WOULD THEN PROVIDED TO RESIDENTS
OF SINGLE FAMILY OR MULTI FAMILY
HOMES.
FOR THE PURPOSES OF CLEAN UP
LEAD PAINT THEIR CONTENT THAT
HAS CONTAMINATED OUR HOMES.
THE FEE WILL ONLY BE A PO
IMPOSED IF INITIATIVE PASSES
THAT STATES THAT LEAD PAINT IS.
NOT A PUBLIC NUISANCE AND ON
DOES THE ACTIONS BY THE COURT.
ADDITIONALLY THE FEE WOULD BE
USED TO PAY FOR THE BOND INSTEAD
OF USING GENERAL TAXPAYER MONEY.
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE GO TO
FUNDING AT TO OTHERWISE GO TO
HEALTH CARE. PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND OTHER PROGRAMS.
LEAD HAS BEEN LISTED IN UNDER
WELL LEAD IS A NEUROTOXIN
THERE'S NO.
LEVEL OF LEAD THAT IT'S BEEN
PROVEN SAFE EITHER FOR CHILDREN
OR ADULTS.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN AFTER
THIRTEEN YEARS OF LITIGATION
SANTA CLARA SUPERIOR COURT
JUDGE.
JAMES KLEINBERG
FOUND THAT PAINT MANUFACTURERS
SOLD LEAD CONTAMINATED PAINT
KNOWING THAT OPPOSED TO SERIOUS
HEALTH RISK TO RESIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT THE PAINT
MANUFACTURERS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PAIN TO REMOVE HER OBEY TO LET.
ALL THIS CASE WAS UPHELD IN THE
IN THE APPELLATE COURT AND
DECLINED BY THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT.
IN SPITE OF THE COURT'S
FINDINGS OF LEAD PAINT
MANUFACTURERS ARE PROPOSING
INITIATIVE FOR THAT NOVEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN STATEWIDE
BALLOT.
REVERSED THE COURT'S RULING
SPECIFICALLY THE INITIATIVE
WOULD.
RELIEF PAINT MANUFACTURERS OF
LIABILITY.
.
AND UNDO THE ACTIONS BY MULTIPLE
COURTS AND PUT THE SOLE
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR.
ARE ON CALIFORNIA'S POOR NOW WHY
DO I SAY IT WOULD PUT IT ON THE
POOR. VERY SIMPLY THERE IS A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR BOND THAT MEANS
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS THAT COME
OUT OF THE STATE FUND.
ARE UNDER PROP NINETY EIGHT I
BELIEVE THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS WILL
BE HELD HARMLESS THIS COME
MOSTLY OUT OF HEALTH AND WELFARE
PROGRAMS.
THIS BOND ISSUE DIRECT TAX ON
THE POOR.
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITNESSES PARK I BILL ELLIOTT
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP.
I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON RED AND
TAX BY KNOW THAT ABOUT LEAD
POISONING AND ITS EFFECTS ON
TOXICITY ON LITTLE ONES AS WELL
AS LEAD WORKER AND WORKERS.
DE LET COMPANIES IN THIS CASE
KNEW WHAT THEY WERE DOING AND
THAT'S WHY THE LAWSUIT HAPPENED
AND THEY LOST SO THEY'RE TRYING
TO FOR OUR WAY AROUND AT THE KEY
PROVISION IN THAT INITIATIVE
SAYS. LET US NOT A PUBLIC
NUISANCE THAT'S WHAT'S BURIED IN
THERE AND A SELL JOB OF THE
PUBLIC VOTE FOR YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO CLEAN UP ASBESTOS IN MOLTEN
LEAD. AND ALL THAT AND MEANWHILE
I THINK THE IMPACT HERE. IS ON
THE PUBLIC AGAIN FOR THAT
GENERAL FUND IT'S BEEN ASKED
WAIT TILL YOU'LL PAY ME NOW
THROUGH THE. THROUGH THE BOND
MEASURE OR BY INC DOES THIS
RAISE THE PRICE OF PAINT.
BUT WE THINK IT'S MORE.
ABOVE BOARD TO SAY LET'S MIDDLE
SAY WHAT IT REALLY IS HERE AND
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT YOU WILL PAY
IF THIS BOMB MEASURE PASSES SO
THIS IS A. NOT A WAY AROUND THAT
AND A GOOD WAY TO ADDRESS THE
PUBLIC THAT'S WEBER SUPPORTING
THIS AND THE OTHER PACKAGES IN
THE LEAD PAINT BILL THANK YOU
THE OTHER BILL IN THE LEAD PAINT
PACKAGE THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
MICHAEL RATIGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY HERE IN SPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PAUL LATER
SHUDDER INTO AND WE HAVE THE
SITTING COUNTIES HAVE SINCE GONE
SUPPORT.
CAPTION AND CHAIR MEMBERS
STREETS APART ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY PARTICIPER VISORS
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY AFTERNOON I'M HEIDI
MCAULIFFE WITH AMERICAN COATINGS
ASSOCIATION.
I'D LIKE TO TALK TO A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE COATINGS
ASSOCIATION THE COATINGS
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE OVER TWO HUNDRED
MANUFACTURERS ITSELF PRODUCT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE EMPLOY
OVER THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
OUR INDUSTRY PAYS ABOUT AN
AVERAGE OF FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO OUR WORKERS. AND WE
SUPPORT A PAYROLL OVER ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF OUR.
WE LIKE TO CALL ONE OF OUR TOP
TEN STATES WE HAVE A VERY LARGE
FOOTPRINT OF MANUFACTURERS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR MEMBERS.
INCLUDE A LOT OF COMPANIES THAT
MAKE.
A VERY WIDE VARIETY OF
CATEGORIES OF PRODUCTS
OF THE PAIN INDUSTRIES CONSISTS
OF MANY MANY DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES. MANY OF WHICH ARE
SOLD AT RETAIL A LOT OF VERY
SPECIALTY NICHE PRODUCTS SOLD AT
RETAIL LIKE AEROSOL PAINTS
AUTOMOTIVE AND MARINE PAINTS.
TRAFFIC AND ROAD MARKING PAINTS
INDUSTRIAL MAINTENANCE COATINGS.
AND RECYCLED CONTENT COATINGS
JUST TO NAME A FEW.
I I BELIEVE THAT YOU ALL SHOULD
HAVE A LIST OF.
OVER TWO HUNDRED MANUFACTURERS
THAT ACTUALLY SELL PAINT AT
RETAIL.
IN CALIFORNIA AND I JUST LIKE
THE.
GO OVER A COUPLE OF THESE.
NAMES OF THESE PRODUCTS.
ACRYLIC TEX COATINGS AND
RECYCLING INCORPORATED AMAZON
ENVIRONMENTAL FAIR PROCESS
CORPORATION. CAMEO SPECIALTY
PRODUCTS.
CHALK COUNTRY PAIN CUSTOM PAINT
PRODUCT GROUP.
DON EDWARDS CORPORATION ECO
STEPS COATINGS.
ENVIRO CARE CORPORATION FRANKLIN
PAINT COMPANY.
KELLY MOORE COMPANY. MAD DOG
PAINT PRODUCTS OLIVETTI ORGANIC
FINISHES.
SEE MORE OF SYCAMORE.
SUNNY SIDE CORPORATION TEXTURED
COATINGS OF AMERICA. ENVISIONS
PAINT RECYCLING LET'S JUST A
COUPLE OF THE NAMES I PICKED OUT
REALLY SOME NAMES ON THIS LIST
OF COMPANIES THAT. MANUFACTURE
SORT OF NICHE SPECIALTY TYPE.
PRODUCTS.
PRODUCTS THAT NEVER CONTRIBUTED
TO.
OF THE LEAD THE PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE WITH REGARD TO HIGH BLOOD
LEAD LEVELS.
PRODUCT COMPANIES THAT MAY
NEVER HAVE BEEN IN EXISTENCE
WHEN LEAD WAS THE STATE OF THE
ART TECHNOLOGY AND REQUIRED BY
MANY GOVERNMENT'S.
COMPANIES THAT.
THAT NEVER ENGAGED IN THAT SAW.
IN THAT PRODUCT CATEGORY.
LIKE I SAID A LOT OF THESE ARE
NIECE PRODUCTS.
AND I DO KNOW THAT ALL OF THESE
AS I SAID SELL PRODUCTS AT
RETAIL AND WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THE TAX. THAT WOULD BE IMPOSED
UNDER THIS BILL.
THIS LIST ACTUALLY IS IS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE TO YOU IT'S
LISTED ON THE WEBSITE FOR PAIN
CARE.
AND ALL OF THESE MANUFACTURERS
ARE REGISTERED AS SELLING
PRODUCTS AT RETAIL.
SO AGAIN A LIKE I SAID A LOT OF
THESE ARE SMALL MEDIUM SIZE
COMPANIES NIECE PRODUCTS AND
ADDED TAX ON TOP OF THESE
PRODUCTS WOULD. WOULD PROVE.
VERY MUCH A DIFFICULTY OF FOR
THESE COMPANIES IN ESTABLISHING
THEIR NATION CALIFORNIA.
TEN SECONDS.
THANK YOU.
I JUST LIKE TO URGE YOU TO VOTE
AGAINST THIS BILL IT'S UNFAIR TO
THE REST OF THE PAIN COATINGS
INDUSTRY. IT HOLDS TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE COMPANIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE HISTORIC
MANUFACTURE AND SALE OF LEAD
BASED PRODUCTS WHEN THEY'D NEVER
ENGAGE IN THAT ACTIVITY. IT
HOLDS COMPANIES RESPONSIBLE ONE
MANY WERE NOT IN EXISTENCE.
WHEN THIS WAS THE STATE OF THE
ART TECHNOLOGY. IT HOLDS
COMPANIES RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
BALLOT INITIATIVE WHEN THEY ARE
NOT INVOLVED IN THAT LITIGATION.
OR IN THE PROMOTION OF THE
BALLOT INITIATIVE SO I URGE YOU
TO VOTE AGAINST THIS BILL.
OTHER I DO THINK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
XENA QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SO REMEMBER MELINDA'S.
THANK MADAM CHAIR.
SO I.
HEARD THIS BILL IN ONE OF MY
OTHER COMMITTEES.
AND UNFORTUNATELY WAS NOT ABLE
TO VOTE FOR IT THEN NOR CAN I
VOTE FOR IT TODAY I THINK.
MISTER QUIRK KNOWS WHY NAM I I
JUST FEEL. TWICE I SYMPATHIZE
WITH.
YOUR POINT ABOUT THE LEAD PAINT.
BUT I STILL THINK THAT IT WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT THE
LOWER INCOME FOLKS BECAUSE THE
TAX WILL BE PASSED ON TO THEM.
SO.
PEOPLE HAVE A FEW EXTRA BUCKS IN
A POCKET IT WON'T MATTER TO THEM
IT'S THERE'S A MEMBER ON THE
LOWER END OF THE SCALE I WILL
SAY THAT.
.
JUST.
TO BE FAIR.
THE LIST THAT WE WERE GIVEN
HERE OF I KNOW HOW MANY OVER.
TWO HUNDRED DIFFERENT PAINT
COMPANIES ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL.
.
WE WOULD EXPECT PAINT COMPANIES
TO BE AGAINST THIS BILL SO I
DON'T KNOW THAT THIS MOVES THE
NEEDLE FOR OUR FOR ANYONE WHO
MIGHT BE ON THE FENCE ABOUT THIS
BILL BECAUSE.
THIS AFFECTS ALL OF THEM SO
NATURALLY THEY WOULD BE AGAINST
SOMETHING THAT INCREASE THEIR
COSTS JUST FOR YOUR OWN. AYE
NOTES AYE QUESTION IT'S OKAY I
JUST ONE YEAR AND NOW I JUST
CLARIFY THAT NO I DON'T NEED
CLARIFICATION I JUST BUT THAT'S
NOT A LIST OF COMPANIES THAT ARE
OPPOSED TO IT.
THAT'S JUST A LIST OF COMPANIES
THAT SELL PAINT INTO CALIFORNIA
OKAY FAIR ENOUGH WELL IT IT'S
PRESENTED AS THOUGH THESE ARE
THIS IS A LIST OF OPPOSITION IS
WELL I JUST WANTED YOU.
TO BE.
AND WE UNDERSTOOD WHAT I'M
SAYING GREAT OF COURSE WE WOULD
OUR ACT.
SO BUT AGAIN I THINK IT GOES
BACK TO THE COST BE IS ALWAYS
PASSED ON TO THE CONSUMER.
WE KNOW THAT TO BE TRUE AND SO
FOR THOSE REASONS I'M I'M NOT
ABLE TO SUPPORT IT.
MISTER CURRY THANK YOU OUT FIRST
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
THE GIFT.
AND THEN POSSIBLY WANT TO
ADDRESS A FEW THINGS THAT.
THAT THERE IS A COST THERE'S NO
FREE LUNCH ON THIS ISSUE AND SO
WHETHER IT'S.
HOW PASSED ON THE CONSUMER
PASSED ON OF THE TAXPAYER IS THE
QUESTION I THINK THAT THE AUTHOR
IS IS BRINGING UP THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE IF IT IS THAT?
A BOND THAT GOES BEFORE THE
VOTERS SIMPLE MATHEMATICS SHOWS
THAT THAT MONEY HAS TO COME FROM
SOMEWHERE. THE FIFTY M..
IF THE AB BOND PASSES AND THAT
COMES OUT OF EXPENDITURES THAT
WE MAKE IN MY BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND ALL ACROSS THE STATE AND.
.
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW WE
ALREADY HAVE.
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA. PAINT MATCHES
BATTERIES ALREADY.
BUT THIS IS ISN'T IT AN
ADDITIONAL COST AND THEM I JUST
WONDER MISTER. MISTER QUIRK IF
YOU COULD EXPLAIN ONE MORE THE
SKY LIKE A TRIPLE FLIP TYPE
THING IS THE. ONLY.
GOES INTO A FACT RIGHT IF THE
MEASURE.
PASSES.
THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S CORRECT AND
YOU NAY EVEN BETTER IF THE
MEASURE WITH WITH TROTTER THEM I
COULD WITHDRAW MY DENTAL. BUT IF
IT IF THE MEASURE. PASSES AND
YOUR BILL.
FAILS.
THEY'RE STILL MOST LIKELY WOULD
BE.
A ON.
I'M PSYCHED IF IF THE.
THE MEASURE FAILS AND THEY WIN
THEIR COURT DECISION.
YOU MEAN THE COUNTIES.
YES
SO THEN THE LEAD PAINT COMPANIES
WHO WHERE. SELLING LEAD PAINT
COULD PAY THE PRICE.
AND IT'LL HOW THAT IT'S FAST ON.
WELL WHO KNOWS.
I AGAIN I'M NOT GOING TO
SPECULATE.
I DO KNOW THAT IF.
THE BOND PASSES.
THAT.
THE COSTS WILL BE PAID BY THE
POOREST PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE MONEY
WILL COME OUT OF.
YEAH THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE ARE PERCOLATE CLOSE.
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AGAIN PLEASE PROTECT THE POOR
IN CALIFORNIA AND ALLOW THIS
BILL TO GO ONTO THE NEXT STAGE
THANK YOU.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WAS
HIGHLY CALDERON.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS IS A
MINUTE TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE AYE PEARL.
BONTA. BONTA AYE CHU. CHU AYE
GRAY MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
MELINDA SNOW MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE VOEPEL.
THE POLO.
IT TO THE TOP THAT THOSE SIXTY
TWO IT'S OUT.
OKAY ANYTHING THANK YOU WITH AN
ASTERISK DECLINE BECAUSE. HURRY
MOVING TO HIGHLIGHT ENDS ON CALL
VIOLATED ONE EP EIGHTEEN SIXTY
THREE. MS ISLAND KALI ABSENTEE.
MEMBERS.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE GRAY.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
THE PLANT ITSELF THAT BILL IS
OUT EIGHT TO ONE FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE.
WILL LIFT THE CALL CALLING
ABSENTEE MEMBERS.
BONTA. BONTA AYE GRAY.
SO.
THAT BILL IS OUT SIX TO TWO.
I MEAN IF I FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
THREE THOUSAND.
CALL THE ABSENTEES BURKE AYE
BURKE AYE BONTA. BONTA AYE GRAY.
MULLIN.
MULLIN ON.
SEVEN ZERO.
WE CONTINUE ON.
THAT PUTS
CAME UP WITH THAT BILLOWED OUT
LIVING IT.
WE CAN YOU HAPPENS HOLD ON.
I AND NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY FOUR CALLING ABSENTEES
BONTA. BONTA I'M MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
THE PROPHETIC LIVING A FILE ITEM
FIVE AB TWENTY THIRTY THREE CALL
THE ABSENTEES BONTA.
BONTA AYE.
MOVING A FILE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY TO CALL THE
ABSENTEES BONTA. BONTA AYE.
MINUTES PLEASE.
YOU'RE HERE FOR NUMBER FIVE.
YES VOTED AYE.
WE CAN DO IT AGAIN.
OKAY.
I HEAR THE SAME THING WITH
CLEAN.
NOT ABOUT
.
HERE'S
FILE ITEM ONE. A. B. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY THREE KALI ABSENTEES GRAY.
GRAY AYE FILE ITEM TO AB TWENTY
THREE NINETY FOUR CALLING THE
ABSENTEES GRAY.
GRAY I WOULDN'T.
CAVEAT IS BECAUSE YOU S. B. AS
CO AUTHOR ALAN SOME MONEY.
I AM NEVER TO.
AND TO OKAY.
FILE ITEM THREE AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE OF ALL THE
ABSENTEES.
FILE ITEM SEVEN EAGLE. I'M
CERTAINLY MORE NUMBER THREE WE
HAVE A NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY GRAY.
GRAY I.
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB THREE
THOUSAND.
GRAY.
NUMBER ANYWAY NOT VOTING.
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB THREE
THOUSAND THREE AT THIRTEEN OH
NINE. CALL THE ESSENCE.
AB THIRTY ARE NINE GRAY.
GRAY NOW.
GRAY I'M VOTING FOR A NO TO NOT
VOTING.
GRAY NO NOT VOTING.
RENDON TAXES THAT ARE